I think in the UK people are just sort
of reckoning now with the existence of
anti-semitism and I think that that sort
of self interrogation is very difficult
for people I think it's an identity
crisis in the UK people understanding
that anti-semitism does in fact exist
[Music]
I've experienced anti-semitism from
people who are on the far left and the
far right and people who are black and
light men and women anti-semitism is not
restricted to one party or gender or
race any semitism is for everybody this
is the news clip from the late 1950s a
swastika got painted on a synagogue and
leans finally are you worried no not in
the least is nothing to be worried about
one ignores 'i sings i think that's so
british to just be like yes he's nothing
to worry about one ignores these things
but i also think you know that's sort of
the reason that people are surprised
that anti-semitism is a part of the
culture the vast majority of people are
not actively anti-semitic and when
anti-semitic stuff like that did happen
in for many years when it has happened
in sort of lego will wash it off the
wall and get on with business as usual
and now that it's back in the forefront
I think it's shocking for people
precisely because it is the kind of
thing that you would move it's so
interesting to watch this because this
feels like 1933 Doric this war bond
speech sums up so much of anti-semitic
rhetoric because he says not open but
hiding not straightforward but crafty
and then it goes not national but
international it's that tie between
nationalism and anti-semitism that that
Jews are somehow not from here they
don't belong here they're part of this
global cabal that's here - it's here to
take stuff away from us and always the
crafty thing there's no way to describe
Jews that doesn't sound ludicrous when
they go into a sort of that stereotype
they're like they're crafty or sneaky
they're wily I think Jews get bludgeoned
with Israel sometimes I think Israel is
like a very weird lead-pipe for for a
lot of people they're just like well
you're Jewish
so explaining this Israeli policy and
you're like well I don't know if I 100%
agree with that policy because you know
I'm a person with complicated political
views and and they're like well then you
do you think Israel shouldn't exist and
you're like oh no that's not what I said
either like Israel is a very complicated
issue and it is the only sort of Jewish
homeland or not so for that reason Jews
do have a a special affiliation with it
and it is a place by the way where I I
love my time in Israel because it is one
of the only places where I do not feel
other for being Jewish I've taken issue
with you know many of its policies in
the same way that I take issue with many
of the UK's policies and many American
policies but I do think Israel is used
as a complete mask for for anti-semitism
sometimes or it's used to justify
anti-semitism my favorite quote about
anti-semitism is this jean-paul sartre
coat which is that if the Jew did not
exist and the anti-semite would have to
invent him and I think about that all
the time I do think that a good way to
reduce any Semitism is for people to to
understand that you know that Jew is a
label or Jew as a type is a label that
is entirely constructed it doesn't mean
that you are you know a type of person
or a certain way there is a strong
heritage which you may opt into if you
so choose you know I think it's crucial
for people to understand that Jews are
complicated in the same way that
everybody else
there are rich Jews and poor Jews and
Jews who are educated and Jews who are
not and you know if you think all Jews
are sort of powerful and educated and
rich I have a bunch of cousins that you
should meet because it's not the case